welcome to bananamores this next
comedian makes my belly laugh every time
i hear her perform
get ready to do the same introducing
chelewa shop oh mitzi
it's always good to see you
you dame oh hi everyone
how are you guys doing how are you
holding up
yeah oh boy i'm just uh
taking a little breather from work i've
been
lucky enough to work from home you know
i think i mean
i'm not doing anything
and i'm still getting paid
so i'm not going to rock the boat
you know what i mean right yeah i think
i think the issue is
that i'm i'm an office manager
but we are all working from home
which takes the office out of the
equation
and i am not entirely sure what i'm
managing
oh not much it feels like here's what
i'm doing
every day monday through friday here's
what i do
i get up i take a shower
i get dressed i grab my
things i run outside of my apartment
and then i stand outside of my apartment
door
until i am exactly eight minutes late
and then i rush back into my apartment
and i drop my things and i say something
to my cat about the trains
and then i email all of my co-workers to
make sure that they are drinking
terrible coffee
and then i'm kind of done for the day
you know just sit back
kick your feet up drink terrible coffee
in solidarity it's not bad it's not bad
i will say this i am i work with
wonderful people
but i do not miss having to make small
talk with them
uh i tru they're lovely folks but i'm
very bad at small talk
you know did you ever have a hiding spot
at your job to keep from having small
talk like
did you just like hide behind a filing
cabinet or something uh here's what i
would do
i would um i would sit at my desk
and i would make myself very small
just in the hopes that no one would see
me over my monitor
you know it usually worked
um except for the fact that
my desk is the front desk and it is
literally my job to greet everyone
that comes in and i am bad at it
i'm so bad at my job in person
thrilled to be doing it from home
i mean you know a co-worker would come
by and say hey did you
how about this weather did you hear
about the and i would just
you can cut that chitting and chatting
out that
is not why i'm here i am here
for the wi-fi if you'll excuse me
i have a spinning wheel to attend to
okay i'm just uh i'm not good with
people i'm just not much of a people
person
um once i uh i went to brunch
with three couples
i don't think that's my fault do you
know what i mean like
one couple invited me and then when i
got there i thought oh
well you you should have told me i would
have hired someone to come with me
to this isn't fair this is not fair
there came a moment when uh when the
waitress came by
and they stopped her to tell her how to
separate the checks
so they they stopped the waitress and
they said
okay so these two people here
they're on one check and then these two
they're on another and this is exactly
what the waitress did she looked at us
and said
yeah i think i can figure this out
oh really you uh you cracked the case
what uh what was the first clue was it
that we're sitting at a
six top table and i'm the only one with
a plate in my lap
is that how you got it yeah that's great
that's great
but i do have to say that uh when the
checks arrived
i was the only one who didn't have to
have that
quiet yet furious conversation with
someone else
to figure out how we're going to pay for
these 18 eggs
i just tossed down my debit card and
said overdrawn all by myself i don't
need a man
i sure don't you can get any money off
of that card
eggs on me forever all legs on me
all eggs on me oh
mitzi you know what i don't want to take
up any more of your time
so i'm just going to get going but uh
thank you for letting me come up here
and tell
my little jokes my name is chile rashard
thank you very much
a banana more's instant legend the
banana more stage is lucky to have that
chilewa sharp let me tell you i'm gonna
tell you
i seriously go bananas for this guy
that's why he's perfect for banana mores
welcome back to jimmy kimmel live i'm
jimmy kimmel
i'm the jimmy that you watch when fallon
is too much drew barrymore is one of the
most beloved personalities and actors of
all time
here with us today are some celebrities
that want to share that love
first up seth rogen
you know my first movie was withdrew
barrymore it was uh donnie darko
really freaky movie her uh production
company flower films produced it
pretty awesome right and as you know i
love plants
if you know what i mean
uh yeah seth i think we all know what
you mean uh vince vaughn what do you
think
you know uh drew barrymore is one of the
greatest actors of all time if you don't
believe that
that that's crazy you know you know i
could have been in the wedding singer as
well but instead i was in swingers
you see what i did there you know it's
pretty clever it's pretty you know i
actually love the 80s you know i could
have actually been in the wedding singer
because i love devo i love the hats you
know that's the thing about ohio
yeah let me stop you right there vince
we only have so much time on this show
uh nick offerman what do you think
the name drew barrymore evokes
quality beauty and dependability
much like a fine mahogany kayak or a
smooth age scotch wow nick offerman a
real handyman you know he actually built
my porch
true story uh robert downey jr uh yeah
hi uh you know drew and i were 80s party
kids that only grew up to be
uh beloved you know adults a very
chilled out
namaste uh you're great i'm great
there's nothing to debate thank you all
right and finally we have john hamm
[Laughter]
john hamm drew barrymore
two very attractive people
deal with it short and sweet ham i love
it
uh well that's all the time that we have
for tonight's show drew you're amazing
we love you
and my apologies to matt damon for not
getting to him in time
all right see you later good night
a banana loss instant legend the banana
more stage is
lucky to have that one i'll tell ya oh
what a treat
banana moss makes me hungry for more
comedians like this next one
thank you so much mitzi for having me um
my name is maya bishmuk um i will be
doing some
characters today i do hate myself so
i like to play other people it's a lot
easier that way you'll be happy
i'll be happy we'll all be happy
together so let's just go through some
of my favorite
pandemic characters of the year
you know her you hate her she's
the preachy privileged one i know this
is a
super trying time but guess what i
found that it's brought me a lot of
purpose and meaning plus i'm rich and my
parents have land
and i've been focusing on my hobbies
like
picking out ethnic tapestries and making
indian food using my pantry staples
plus financially i know it's hard for a
lot of people but i'm utilizing the
government
i've just taken out my fit ppp loan for
17 million dollars
for my small company that makes beige
cable knit sweaters
we only sell between amagansett and sag
harbor
oh it's gonna be okay i'm not even in my
home i'm actually in guatemala
this is another character this is
relatable it's
we've all been her okay it's the woman
who can't scratch her face
i really wish i could scratch my face
right now
i love cardi b this is a total
non-sequitur i think she's so fantastic
i feel like she is so interesting and
and brilliant
and um she's taught us a lot about
female physiology that we were affair to
talk about
but um this is what i imagine she
actually is doing
in this time okay
so a lot of y'all know me as the canary
in the coal mine for the pandemic when i
yell
coronavirus corona virus
well listen y'all i have two weeks
so i just figured that i will do a
little collaboration y'all with fashion
nova and
merc and i created a vaccine y'all oh
it's a party's corona cure
and like you guys i'm so happy you're
like
i am so blessed that you all love me and
support me
but like you'll be hating
i know a lot of y'all be like damn cardi
what do you know about
immunology a lot i know a lot
all i know is that when you get your
first dose
your t cells are going to be like
and your b cells are going to be like
eew
and your assy bodies are going to be
like oh
but this is not your regular regular
schneck in a vaccine y'all
is super safe 99 percent of faxes
and we will be at every walgreens
starting on my birthday
eel
thank you guys so much for having me
have a great
safe beer thank you
i gotta watch that set again let's
rewind
as jlo once said let's get loud
clap it up for that incredible set